[Musique]
ce qu'on mange un impact direct sur
notre environnement
que doit-on faire pour rendre notre
assiette plus verte
j'en discute avec leur batterie dell aux
crises etc ou sociologues qui milite
depuis des années pour le commerce
équitable la consommation responsable et
le développement durable larmes à
ridelles s'est fait des années qu'on
vous voit essayé nous convaincre qu'il
faut sauver la planète
c'est urgent est-ce qu'on peut changer
l'avenir de la planète en commençant par
le sud je pense qu'un atrassi hatley on
peut en faire carrément un projet de
société
si on ose réfléchir en aide modèle agro
alimentaire qui revoir des choix pied à
cet égard les consommateurs ils ont un
pouvoir tellement plus grands qui serait
porté à croire dans les dernières années
on a vu plein d'initiatives de gens qui
se disaient on est capable de faire un
changement préserver la pandémie
l'impression on a reculé de 5 10 c'est
vrai ou pas mais je dirais qu'on a
reculé sur le plan des déchets
alimentaires notamment on est beaucoup
dans le temps le jetable quoique bien et
restaurateurs et c'est d'aller vers des
contenants compostables et tout ça mais
par contre je pense que une prise de
conscience notamment sur le plan de la
sécurité alimentaire pi du lac halal
tout d'un coup on a vu que c'était
important d'être capable de se nourrir à
l'intérieur de nos frontières que c'est
important de soutenir nos agriculteurs
que l'on était dépendant d'une main
d'oeuvre extérieure donc on a vu notre
vulnérabilité à beaucoup d'égards et je
pense que ce choc là nous a amenés nous
amène tranquillement à faire d'autres
choix pour justement revoir notre modèle
qui contribuera aussi espérons le à
réduire la taille de notre empreinte
écologique mais comment vous réussir ça
à réduire l'empreinte écologique de
notre as you may et plein plein de
choses qu'on peut faire on réalise que
parmi ce qu'est le plus d'impact
notamment sur le climat c'est de réduire
le gaspillage alimentaire le gaspillage
diminue pop se fait des hommes
qu'on en parle qu'est ce qu'on comprend
pas oui ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle
mais en même temps moi je vois quand
même de plus en plus de gens passer de
la parole aux actes et la prise de
conscience
elle est de plus en plus présente donc
je pense qu'il faut continuer à pousser
on du gaspillage alimentaire c'est fou
parce que non seulement ça n'impacte
environnementale est désastreux mais en
plus de ça on a des gens qui ont fait ou
au canada on est à peu près à 8% de la
population qui est en insécurité
alimentaire selon cette ce canada ça
c'est presque une personne sur dix alors
qu'on gaspille autant que l'autre
élément sûr lesquels on eu beaucoup
d'impact c'est la consommation de viande
donc si on réduit notre consommation de
viande et de produits animaux ont réduit
aussi la pression sur les systèmes
agricoles et aussi sur les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre vers entend bien
lorsque vous nous dites mais ça fait des
années que vous le dis ça fait des
années que plein d'experts le dise on
arrive de l'alberta à l'automne dernier
on y est épié consommation biens
augmente il ya quand même une prise de
conscience à quand on regarde les jeunes
y beaucoup plus de jeunes qui réduisent
leur consommation de viande et de
produits animaux que les plus âgés même
le guide alimentaire canadien reconnaît
qu'on a tout intérêt pour des raisons de
santé même pas des raisons
environnementales et qu'ils évoquent à
réduire la consommation de ces produits
là se tourner plus vers des protéines
végétales passé plein temps avec des
décideurs ce que vous avez l'impression
que ça change de ce côté là aussi les
producteurs vont nous dire c'est
beaucoup les grandes chaînes qui ont le
dernier mot paix qui vont nous demander
d'avoir des produits parfaits puis
d'avoir des formats parfait puis après
seules les grandes chaînes vos mesures
c'est les consommateurs qui veulent ça
est ce qu'à un moment donné on va se
parler
je pense que tout le monde souhaite
aller vers une réduction d'empreinte
écologique dans le disco mais le défi
c'est justement de la part de nos
décideurs qui eux vont prendre des
décisions qui ont un impact sur tout le
système de passer de la parole aux actes
parce que toujours de la résistance au
changement partout à tous les éléments
donc ça prend des moyens la mise en
place de l'édition par exemple dans le
cas du gaspillage alimentaire de la
france s'est dotée d'une loi il
encourage les mesures qui font en sorte
qu' on va récupérer davantage et par
exemple dans le cas d'une grande surface
maintenant elles sont obligées de donner
les aliments qui sont proches d'être
périnée le panier d'épicerie du
consommateur c'est quoi les gestes les
plus concrets qui pourrait avoir un
impact énorme sur la planète consomme
moins dix ans impliquant farnese témoins
moins gaspiller ça implique
avant d'aller à l'épicerie on réfléchit
à ce qu'on a vraiment besoin on veut
juste parce que c'est spécial
autant possible d'acheter des produits
biologiques locaux
quand ceux des produits importés des
produits équitables pour assurer que les
gens en ont reçu un salaire décent
évidemment mais aussi l'emballage en
partie que l'emballage ou c'est un
impact sur l'environnement
là cet égard les yeux un petit bémol par
exemple des fois les gens vont avoir
tendance à acheter en vrac ce qui est
une bonne chose si on gaspille pomme
mais il ya aussi des gens des fois
qu'ils achètent en vrac
puis après seuls les allemands sont mal
conservés puis ça fait en sorte que ya
plus de gaspillage donc là on perd les
bénéfices
la réduction de l'emballage comment on
peut garder espoir utilement le ce qui
me semble être là la chose la plus
importante c'est de réaliser qu'on a
tous du pouvoir quand on se met ensemble
on peut vraiment aller vers des grandes
transformations qui sont systémiques
parce que oui c'est le système ultime
ans qu'il faut changer
mais ce système le changera jamais si
y'a pas des citoyens des consommateurs
des entrepreneurs des décideurs qui
disent pas qui mais là on va être
cohérent qui agissons en fonction du
monde qu'on veut pour nos enfants
de tout temps l'alimentation nous a
rassemblé 1 et les l'élire poels un peu
moins grave
covin mais globalement c'était c'est
est-ce donc utilisons ce partant de
notre assiette pour faire délier avec
ceux et celles qui nous nourrissent et
avec l'environnement
je savais que vous aviez nous faire du
bien merci johan femmes plaisait